Some of the challenges for data center networking include traffic load balance,
support for migrating virtual machines, in
response to changing demands. Adjusting server
and traffic placement to save power.
Provisioning the network, when demands fluctuate,
and providing various security guarantees, particularly
in scenarios that involve multiple tenants.
To understand these challenges, in a bit more detail, let's take a look at
a typical data center topology. A topology
typically has three layers: an access layer, which
connect the servers themselves. An aggregation layer
which connects the access layer, and then the
core. Historically, the core of the network
has been connected with layer three, but increasingly,
modern data centers are connected with
an entire layer-two topology. A layer-two topology
makes it easier to perform migration of services from one part of the topology
to another, since these services can stay on the same layer-two network and
hence would not need new IP addresses when they moved. It also becomes easier to
load balance traffic. On the other hand,
a monolithic layer-two topology makes scaling difficult, since
now we have tens of thousands of servers on a single flat topology. In other
words, layer-two addresses are not topological. So
the forwarding tables in these switches can't scale
as easily, because they can't take advantage of
the natural hierarchy that exists in the topology.
Other problems that exist in this type of
topology, is that the hierarchy can potentially create single
points of failure. And links at the top of
the topology, in the core, can be come oversubscribed.
Modern data center operators have observed that as you
move from the bottom of the hierarchy up towards
the core, that the links at the top can
carry as much as 200 times as much traffic
as the links at the bottom of
the hierarchy. So there's a serious capacity mismatch
in that the top part of the topology has to carry a whole lot more
traffic than the bottom. We'll explore how
modern data center network architectures address these various
challenges, but let's first take a quick look
at one way of solving the scale problem.